hey everybody and welcome to a comedic
wild ride with steo I say that because
this week's guest Mark Norman has got to
be the most pure comedian I've ever met
the guy was born for this he lives for
this he breathes it it's just nonstop
with him and it's so fun to be around
him man and we go kind of nuclear on uh
Howard Stern
I mean I don't know dude it's it's tough
and and and like what do we got to lose
you know like Wai until you hear how
juicy that part gets wow and uh Mark
Norman's very hung over it's uh it's
pretty wild the whole time and I
remember thinking oof this one is going
to get us in trouble so let's see if
that happens everybody let's get into it
it's like 700 years
old and he I did his podcast he was
skating when I showed up he's his body
like clicks you he's like an old printer
for sure you know he's so banged up he's
got 18 plates in his ass and you know
rod in his dick is he competing in the
next X Games I saw that no way he jumped
into the best trick contest I remember
that um I mean dude that was funny we're
gonna have to keep that in keep it in I
I love Tony yeah oh hey what color do
you want for the sign ooh what do you
got blue oh D blue coming right up pal
what variation the blue
yeah the gayest one you got gay I just
go full pink oh let's do pink yeah boom
pink it is man all right all right man
uh since we are
rolling he not on who cares I uh want to
congratulate you on your special man oh
thank you sir it's it's doing well and
Netflix let me keep the RW the Holocaust
slavery I couldn't believe it you really
really uh made every effort to offend
every person well if you get everybody
then you're all right you know I'm I'm
inclusive yeah wasn't nor McDonald
getting in trouble for the r word then
he came on to to keep apologizing for
the r word and just kept make it him
worse I yeah well Norm you know who knew
he had cancer this whole time and uh you
know they they're canceling this guy and
you're like let the man die in peace you
[__] guzzlers Jesus Christ that's the
time when he should have came out that
he had leave him alone I know that's how
much Integrity he had yeah he was he was
epic he was the guy did he really care
that people were upset about it he did I
think his agents were like dude like you
can't say that so he went on to
apologize and he kept saying the art
like I just you
know what what what was the Forum in
which he was using this offensive word
he said it on Howard Stern armer which
is a big platform obviously and uh he
kept throwing it around right and I
think he said I have a
nephew with Down syndrome and autism are
you offended when people say I I'm not
like I me I'm not like know we can cut
that out I don't know if we can say it
on YouTube I I don't know that that's a
problem yeah it was the hard R we sound
like
Pirates you
know ah man this is great so so uh
you're one of few people who has the
distinction of having been on the Wild
Ride podcast now twice and both times in
person very few people hell yeah we did
the New York one yeah and uh you were at
Gotham Studios and it was an honor to
meet you you know watch you forever and
now here we are in the van getting
molested you went on their podcast uh
samarel oh that's right yeah you did my
drunk oh I forgot that was a great EP
well was it cool man yeah you got real
you opened up we kissed it was great
yeah dude yeah lady was there this is
your dog yeah I remember so this is
Netflix special superp To Nuts oh yeah
is it your first special first special
on Netflix first I did a half hour on
Netflix they really make you earn it
when you're a big straight honky um so I
did a half hour and then before that I
did a YouTube special for for an hour
and then I did a Comedy Central hour and
that a Comedy Central half hour so I've
been through the ringer wow how about
that so that's all new material every
time every time different material and
now I've put this out and I'm out of
material and I'm doing the road just
half baked premises trying to peace meal
it together and it's not pretty 20
minutes on lizo Jonah Hill huh oh what
about that submarine those queefs were
billionaires you know and I'm just
trying to [__] my way through it I
love that that that's a strong way to
promote your tour oh yeah come see me
frazzle up there and freak out cuz I'm
I'm panicking hey you know what I think
you can get away with that because
you're just genuinely hilarious I don't
think anybody's going to be dissuaded by
the idea of oh dude we're gonna go watch
Mark Norman work on new material that in
itself is uh pretty if I was gay I'd
blow you so thank you yeah yeah it it's
going pretty well I'm pulling it off you
know because the audience knows you now
and that that's half the battle when
they know you they can meet you halfway
they get what you're saying they get
what you're trying to say but strangers
that's the hard people to make laugh
that dud that that's really the
phenomena of podcasting how people
legitimately get to know you exactly
yeah you're in people's ear and and
their ass all day and it's it's nice
well what I couldn't believe is that you
were a janitor for many years who look
who did the research I was watching some
podcasts before and some interviews what
was that like being a janitor was it
just a [__] stalker a weird creep
well done sir are those Warby Parker I
believe so yeah me too it's all I wear
fatty um
yeah shout out to warie love those
Jews uh oh yeah janitor actually you
know janitor sounds like a rough gig it
was a great gig headphones in nobody
told me what to do you know it's labor
you don't have to use your brain so I
just thought of jokes all day or I
listen to podcast all day or music mop
on the floor it was great a janitor
where uh New York City had a hedge fund
like in a skyscraper and I was in charge
of I think four or five floors so I'd
have to People's Furniture I had to you
know clean the bathrooms it'd be a big
old Bowl miscarriage in there and I had
to clean that out and then uh you know
there'd be like a posum and the aviation
duck so I had to get that out so it it
had its bad parts but I'd take that over
like a desk job any day did you find
yourself coming up with material while
you're like mopping the floor tons of
material I have a whole janitor Chunk in
my one of my specials from years ago uh
I I would write in the boiler room like
a psycho cuz I didn't you know I didn't
want to waste any time and uh yeah it
was a great gig any low low thought gig
what low uh not using brain power yeah
you don't want to go do data entry or
spreadsheets I'd kill myself but you
know nice and easy moppin Tom Petty and
the blower you know having a great time
I love it dude was that during the
financial crash or right after or was a
lot of empty
floors it was right after it was in the
Twin Towers that really made it hard no
I'm just kidding um
but uh yeah it was right after that it
was like that was in 2008 and I think
this was like 2010 11 so yeah a lot of
hedge fun and and I was the white guy
janitor so everybody thought I was like
a a criminal or a drug addict or
something you I'd have guys in suits be
like what's up man what are you doing
what are you janitor what you're you're
white work for us my white alarm um but
yeah and it was great great great gig
really yeah I loved it the pay was [__]
[__] sorry little saing
um the pay was [__] but uh nobody
bothered me it was awesome yeah it's
probably a good job to be hung over to
if you nobody clean up your own vomit
nobody's bothering you yeah totally
you're wildly hung over right now oh I'm
hurting man we did it up last night we
did the store all night drinking free
drinks all these friends are in town I
don't get out here enough and then I
left the store I'm staying at hotel
Ziggy which is across the street so I
stumbled across the street I see pink
dot you know the convenience store yeah
I go in there and I buy a couple of
bottles of who knows what and then I get
a bunch of guys back to the hotel and we
just kept going and uh one of my friends
car got towed cuz we just kept drinking
all night I think I went to think I went
to bed at about 6:30 a.m. nice and I
woke up and did some other guy's pod and
now I'm in a van with a couple of
weirdos yep that's that's that's good
stuff man yeah no place at I'd rather be
thank you yeah what uh how many podcasts
you do you have we might be drunk is
that it no I got we might be drunk which
is a tough one because you drink or I do
so it's like we'll do two in a day and
it's noon and I'm hammered and I got
shows at night or whatever and then I
have another one called Tuesdays with
stories which is me and a buddy Joe list
and he goes on the road I go on the road
we come back we tell the tales of the
heckles the fist fights the the travel
you name it and yeah those are the two
and they're going good we have you on
the other one we don't have guests yeah
yeah not to worry man not to worry we
got uh we just we just booked Sam is is
it marel maril yeah yeah maril it's a
weird Russian Jew name Sam
Marill um he's gonna be great right oh
he's a killer hilarious great comic he's
got an nli special as well and hell of a
joke one of the best joke writers In The
Biz so what does better for your comedy
having a Netflix special or going on
Rogan that's a good question the Rogan
thing is good but I think it used to be
bigger you know like before the Spotify
the bump yeah so uh I'd say a Netflix if
the Netflix special clicks like seura
just put one out and it was in the top
10 for two three weeks it was huge
number one number one yeah so that I
think is big and it's Global you know
that thing goes out to the whole goddamn
world as some guy in a Hut in India
going hey this guy's funny and then
Rogan uh is also great but if the
special's good I think the special beats
it but there's a lot of bad specials out
there there's a ton of bad specials out
there so if your special's bad I think
Rogan's better so is is is Howard Stern
like is big as he was like are you guys
trying to get on Howard Stern anymore to
promote I mean that I would love to I
mean I'm a huge fan as a kid he's gotten
a little queefy over the years you know
he's not what he used to be he used to
be fun as hookers he's throwing cold
cuts at a woman's ass and there's a
weird black crackhead great great stuff
be juice yeah Beetlejuice and now it's
kind of like oh hey I shouldn't have
said this and you're like get out of
here you cashed all those checks when
you were in blackface you son of a [__]
and uh now you're like oh I've evolved
oh come on you Jerry curled hee get out
of
here why do you think that is cuz he
switched to AGT and got family friendly
that's what it is yeah and and I think
the
changed I don't know about the climate
but uh but distinctly and this this is
close to my heart and it really hurts me
I could say that again it hurts in an
emotional way which is why I'm so glad
this episode is brought to you by better
help because there are certain kinds of
emotional pain that it really is a good
idea to get into therapy to work through
and there are a lot of good reasons to
get into therapy I do it because I want
to protect my relation reltionship I
want to fix the roof before it rains and
that's why better help is so crucial
it's a service online that's matched up
three million people with professional
licensed therapists and they're offering
the listeners of the Wild Ride podcast
10% off your first month if you go to
betterhelp.com
sto that's better h
p.com steo again there are some kinds of
pain that you got to talk about and
that's why you want to get into therapy
so go to betterhelp.com sto to enjoy 10%
off your first month and let's get back
to it because I count 16 different times
that I went on the Howard Stern Show
yeah 16 man I was like a goto man I go
in there every time I went in there I
would do something that just like made
Howard
uncomfortable and that would make just
great radio I'd be stapling my balls to
my leg like I'd be like I me I went in
there and and and uh I swallowed five
goldfish wow yeah like I would take it
to another level I I brought like naked
chicks with me like it was just like
constant craziness I like I remember I
would I had to deal with them that I
would tell him something I shouldn't
tell him about another celebrity y for
every plug
that like I'm going to earn myself a
plug by telling you like who I just did
Knoxville's impotent here we go check
out my new book or whatever right
exactly and um man it was it was just a
lot of fun dude and a plug from Howard
Stern's pretty [__] awesome yeah it d
it it was it was rad it was and um right
and and you know what too is that I
didn't even regularly listen to the
Howard Stern Show for all that time when
I was regularly on it I was just like a
crazy drug addict and and and whatever
you know so like and I was on it all the
time then like uh around the time he got
on uh
AGT he became a judge on America's Got
Talent which no one saw coming right
nobody saw it coming and and he was
great on it you know he was great on it
and then like then he
became like uh family friendly yeah and
like and and and it was about that time
when I got this Serious XM subscription
and I regularly listen to the Howard
Stern Show like not only did I regularly
listen to it but I would only listen to
it on the app on my phone so that when I
got out of the car it would pause the
you know
very careful to not like uh miss any
part of any show like I became like a
die hard he's Great's the best
interviewer hands down and at that time
as soon as I started listening to it
then I couldn't get on the show
anymore like it's so crazy I mean like
they'd let me on the wrapup show and I'd
get on there and talk about you thought
it was because you opened up the
elevator at serus I don't know about
that I don't think that that's got it I
think just because Howard became the
image changed familyfriendly kind of and
like he his standard for the caliber of
guests that he would have on like just
went crazy through the roof plus he
started only doing three days a week
like so there was less opportunities to
get in there right and I just like like
he only wants like super A-list like
major Mega celebrities and uh so I can't
get on the show anymore but the irony it
was better when it was when you were
doing it the show it was a better show
and that's the other thing is that back
in the day he he would ask every guest
like what celebrities have you slept
with how much money do you make like it
was all sex and money like really like
crazy so big time celebrities were
afraid to go on the Howard turn they
didn't want to be asked those questions
and he could pull it out of anybody he
was the best at that but now he isn't do
that anymore because he does he wants to
have like the craziest A-list
celebrities so like everybody knows they
go on there and not be in an
uncomfortable situation he won't put
anybody in an uncomfortable situation so
you think that's why his ratings went
down I don't know what it was probably
right yeah I would say so I mean I grew
up watching him and you watched it for
the crazy [__] like the Arty Lang years
he's nodding off on heroin you know the
the girls getting on the sibian yeah
that was hot I used to rub one out to
that show on E remember that uhhuh I
remember he offered John bobbit like an
obscene amount of money to see his dick
on when he did that big party it was
like a I don't know what it was turn 60s
no no no it was like way it was like in
the 90s I remember I was watching it
like when the whole John bobbit thing
was going on you just kept giving him
$10,000 $10,000 it's crazy when Mark was
just sitting here kind of
like bashing Howard like I got like
really uncomfortable I'm like no no no
no I don't like you know cuz you're not
going to be able to go on I just like
can't go on anyways like what do I even
care but like I I have this reverence
for Howard and I do too and it just
hurts me that he changed cuz I you know
he got a seat at the table being that
guy and then you get to the table
finally and you change it's a bummer
it's like marrying a woman you love and
then she
transitions you know yeah what are you
do in that situation yeah what are we
doing here I likeed your vagina now it's
all [__] up and twisted and
mangled it's but sure I'll still do it
thank you yeah I'll still do it but you
know I'd [__] Elliot Paige but you
know that's very geni
um the uh that threw me right off you
have a memorable Howard Stern experience
out of all the 16 times what I going to
say is that when when my last book came
out my my uh my newest book hard kick in
the nuts it just came out I made a
special video for Howard to try to get
on Howard Stern to promote this
book and and this is when we were at a
venue that was a theater a theater that
was so big that our tour bus was like
parked underneath like in a special like
you know yeah it it wasn't outside the
arena it was it was in an arena but it
wasn't outside it was in it was
underneath and I'm like in the bowels of
this huge impressive thing I said Hey
Howard like
uh um you here I am in this this venue
is so big my bus is is like underneath
it and I show them like the tour bus all
wrapped steo and I'm like like real
proud of it I bought my own tour bus h I
got this book coming out I said I know
you love it when people talk about the
celebrities they've had sex with in my
new book like literally like just lists
it just goes right into every one of
them Howard and like I know you like
people talking about money and I was
like Howard I'm killing it I'm
like I'm gonna tell you everything I'm
like Howard I'm killing it I miss you
dude like I used to be on the show all
the time like 16 times I was on now I
haven't been on in like a decade man
it's like I want my relationship with
you back yeah
and uh I did not get my relationship
with them back what a bummer so so throw
some more
[Music]
stuff I mean I'd love to do the show too
but it just it sucks it's a bummer but
you know look how cute you were look how
young what you don't get a a do for
being handsome you were a handsome guy
back in the day oh I don't know about
that now you look like uh the [__]
keeper but back then you were a cute kid
you have a favorite wack Packer oh man I
liked Bob that was it the
[__] Scott you know what to do yeah Eric
the actor Eric the actor yeah he was fun
you know what to
do yeah I've seen Ry Lang pop up on
different podcasts is he still sober do
you see him around New York ever in the
clubs I do he's a he's a whole different
guy he looks different but his nose is
better yeah it's getting there and his
hair is white now and he's lost a ton of
weight and he's hanging in there and
he's still goddamn hilarious he is but
always going to be hilarious man I love
Arty oh first time I was ever on the
Howard Stern Show the very first
appearance I walked in there and uh I
was like where I said uh like I'm going
to swallow five goldfish that was my
first time on yeah and uh and and and I
think Howard said no you don't have to
do that and I said Howard I didn't come
here to waste your time yeah and and
Arty said God bless you I say he says I
love this guy he says you know how many
people come in here specifically to
waste our time you know and it was just
like I had this uh you know this this
wonderful relationship with Ry that
start that started like at that moment
you know he was always super supportive
of me and uh and and back and forth you
know so I'd love to hear him doing well
yeah what do you think of these CU a lot
of people have you know the climate has
changed as we said and a lot of people
have gone a certain way you know you got
to fit The Narrative or whatever it is
you got to go with the way the wind's
blowing and I mean evidently you don't
because you well I'm nobody I I still
have some freedom in this business you
know I'm not in a Marvel movie but my
point is did they sit up in bed at night
and go man that was fun and uh it's kind
of hard pretending to not s think that
stuff is still funny or do you think
they actually believe their own [__]
they might get into like a relationship
or something and like what types of
people are we talking about here like
big celebrities who used to be kind of
on the edge of your side yeah and then
they they clean up the rack which look
if anybody has a come to Jesus moment
and look I get it people want to keep
their job can you give me an example of
one of these SL well I mean he's a
perfect example okay but other than
Howard uh well there's some comedians I
don't want to name who got huge off of
being irreverent and whatever and now
they're like Amy shamer counts in that
category ah well she I think actress
she's still pretty gnarly pretty gnarly
yeah yeah actors yeah I'm trying to
think of now I'm drawing a blank cuz I'm
so hung over but I I know what you're
saying I think it's just kind of the the
climate and you're like well it's
especially when they they go out and
speak politically and you're like this
[__] guy believes that right right I
can't I can't think of anybody but I
know who you're talking about you know
what I'm talking about yeah and I just
wonder if they're at home in the shower
going like all right I got by another
day you know uh I got through it or if
they're like no no I believe all the
[__] I think they probably get in a
relationship and they like you know say
some of the jokes to their chick or
they're do and they're like the [__] did
you just say and it's like well [__] or
who I used to be Isaac over here actors
that were gnarly and are now
soft I think you can uh word that a
little differently yeah but do you think
the soal climate is going to change back
like like do you think it's going to be
like a pendulum where I hope so but but
you're not going to forget who flipped
it's just weird look if you want to
evolve and you want to be who you are
get it and that's all good but you just
happen to be doing it the exact way that
it's fashionable that's the part that
bothers me like oh that really lined up
perfectly for you how convenient to type
in actors who went woke okay there you
go yeah I I I wonder I try not to use
that term I feel like Tucker Carlson or
something yeah the most woke celebrities
and it's an NBC or MSN article any um
any blowback over the Netflix special uh
not yet I haven't looked too much I
don't I'm not going to dig for it but I
haven't uh you know I haven't had a
lamb's blood smeared on my front door or
anything yet so I mean I just I I think
that you did it very
well I think you did it very well
everything's a joke I made even if I go
down a dicey Road it's always a turn at
the end it's always fun I don't want to
hurt anybody I'm not one of these guys
like I want to walk the room [__] these
[__] I don't get that [__] you're not
Ari no no I'm not Ari no forg man was
AR's Jew special good killer killer for
an anti-semite even
I uh no it was great and it was it was
it's hard to have a niche special about
one topic and have it still be good and
he pulled it off with your special where
did the name come from old investigative
Vinnie asking for the origin story and
I'm going to tell you the origin of a
really good time because it's called
bluechew it's a tablet that's chewable
it's got the same active ingredients as
both Viagra and sealas except it only
costs a fraction of the price and for
the listeners of the wild rde podcast
you can get an entire month supply
totally for free all you pay is five
bucks for shipping now why would you do
this because it's fun man I'm telling
you it is fun except a little bit of
help in the bedroom because you're going
to have a better time man Lux loves it
when I show her my blue tongue and to
get this deal again it's an entire month
supply of bluo tablets for free all you
pay is five bucks for shipping you go to
bluechew.com and use the promo code steo
consult with the medical provider in a
moment you've got your prescription and
that month supply of Bluetooth tablets
is on its way to you for free all you
pay is five bucks for shipping again
it's bluechew.com with the promo code
steo now let's get back to it uh it's an
old term meaning like uh Soup To Nuts at
a at a restaurant you get the soup first
and then you have entree dessert and
then nuts at the end cuz I cover
everything we cover everything A to Z
top to bottom Soup To Nuts did you know
right away that's what you're going to
call it or were you going back and forth
with some other ones I had a bunch of
name I wrote them all down and Soup To
Nuts kept coming up like this one feels
right it feels right and I like an old
timey term my last one was called uh out
to lunch like that guy's out to lunch
you know and then I had still got it so
I like an old oldfashioned term and it
just means we cover everything trans
school shootings race
Holocaust uh gay you name
it yeah man we got it all in do you own
a gun no no never been a gun guy I grew
up in the city and and you're in New
York too right I'm I live in New York
I'm from New Orleans yeah people don't
own a lot of guns in New York yeah the
gun laws in New York are crazy they're C
way more strict than any other state but
you know growing up in Louisiana you
know everybody had a gun but you lived
in a mansion though with security a [__]
box Mansion yeah we should have had a
gun cuz we got robbed all the time but
if if we did we'd got we would have shot
a bunch of people yeah I'm scared of
guns a little like I I'll go you know if
a guy hands me a rifle says shoot that
Crow I can do that but like I'm not I
don't want to be one of those guys in
Phoenix who's got a [__] Glock on his
hip Works a tile company I'm like do you
need the Glock is there a lot of Gunplay
happening at uh in
Tempe so yeah I lived in Arizona and I
was like at the gas station I'm like
dude this guy's a gun on his and
everybody else was like fine with it
right but I was like new there like what
the [__] it's normal open carry yeah and
I would you know cops have like the
highest suicide rate they got a gun on
them at all times so I've thought about
killing myself yeah it's right there
that's why I can't have a gun yeah or a
dildo for that matter I'll put it up my
ass every 10 minutes killing yourself in
sex the uh you make a good point the
statistics show that um gun deaths are
like
predominantly people being killed with
their own gun whether they shoot
themselves with their own gun or like
somebody else takes their gun and shoots
them with it can you imagine that's like
it's like when uh the baseball player
gets hit by the pitch and he's so mad
that the pitcher just beaned him that he
charges the mound and then the pitcher
kicks his ass too or it's like skate
park that we went to in uh where he got
sprayed by his
own yeah yeah I'm justed in my own face
before I know that feeling on accident
some guy come in to rob you you know and
you're like oh I'm not having this
you're taking my stuff doing me wrong no
way pal I'm pulling a gun on you the guy
just takes a gun and shoots you with it
that's what that would happen to me in
two seconds I'm a little [__] do you
have a favorite state to do comedy in
favorite country oh country country or
state well this is the best country for
comedy uh Alo Wuhan was pretty good no
I'm kidding uh Dar four is not bad they
got a funny bone out there no uh I would
say state is tough because Texas was my
favorite man that's a good one I'm going
back almost 10 years they got Dallas
Houston Austin San Antonio I I taped my
first special in a Austin good choice in
2015 I did that yeah where was your
special filmed uh Chicago okay yeah but
a state is tough because California is
great too you got SF La San Diego
Sacramento there's so many good comedy
towns but I I think you got to go by
City okay what's favorite City well
Denver something about [__] Denver my
second special in Denver there you go
it's killer just they get it and they're
like real people they have jobs they
have families and they they don't get
offended and they want to come out and
just hear jokes Utah U Salt Lake City
that's a great one I've really felt that
because this is a theory but but because
like the the heavy Mormonism you know
people have this this this restrictive
limiting like you know repression yeah
repressed like Mormon culture that like
that they really want to let lose more
than anybody it's like Catholic School
girl is going to be the [__] there you
go you go you go to Salt Lake sorry
everybody's all the guys look like out
of work MMA fighters they're covered in
weird tattoos they're all virgins they
can't drink caffeine so you tell a joke
they're like I need this you know
they're [__] in the aisles and then
the women all look like out of work porn
stars they're all t uh big fake tits and
weird bad tan and blonde hair in Utah
yeah yeah there's some hot [__] girls
in Utah oh smoking hot yeah very sexy
ladies cuz they're repressed it's like
said so they got to get it out somewhere
mhm yeah speaking of hot ladies Vinnie
over here he uh that's an ugly
lady what are you
kidding
Vinnie is a can we talk about it Vinnie
yeah go for it I don't care talk about
what are we spilling the beans no no not
yet not on that but I mean if you want
to talk his girlfriend did his
girlfriend did porn whoa and she's hot
good for you we're we're not going to to
direct anybody to any specific website
no that's not out yet uh we're not going
to do but we will say that if anybody
were
[Music]
to search a for for for Vinnie uh
performing acts yeah then then it's out
there to be found yeah who are you Adam
22 over there holy geez let your lady
get plowed huh or are you doing the
plowing both
well not she only did that once with the
really did that once and that was before
we met and that was before we met okay
unlike Adam 22 it was the reverse order
she she plowed the other dude first just
one time check it out now she's plowing
Vinnie well done pretty rad dude I
noticed you were sitting
crooked she's she's um like shockingly
goodlooking really yeah I'm a lucky guy
hell yeah cuz look at me you know I just
don't know how I do it yeah no you're
cute cuddly squeezable yeah oh wow look
look at this Isaac is bringing up can we
see a photo oh man what you think what
you searching dude oh wow she's a looker
hot Tam mly I'd let her rail me in the
pooper I mean yeah I mean we've done
that too she she put a strap on not a
strap on no we just do a little bit of
butt
play noted the but butt like recing for
a dream ass to ass man at least we're uh
uploading our podcasts on Rumble now I
don't I don't know how well this one's
going to fa on the
tube well she's covered there you go
good for you man no offense I pictured
her looking like [__] Ralphie May
so well done well done oh thanks dude
good for you send me some photos of you
guys making out just for proof hey
there's my ex that's what she looked
like man old Ralphie funny guy so what's
the tour looking like now do you have a
whole bunch of cities lined up or do you
kind of just work out material and then
start a tour yeah I live in New York so
during the week you kind of do all the
clubs and you you try out material you
try to hone it perfect it then on the
weekends I go to these theaters I'm
doing uh the ace tonight in in LA in
Downtown LA and then I'm doing Santa San
Diego tomorrow bboa theater bboa theater
that's one we did
uh I think it is the where in the Gas
Lamp District I mean yeah it's epic it's
a beautiful San dieg is a great place
Isaac is saying yes you did all right
there you go I love it there yeah I mean
dude the San Diego rules especially for
an East Coast guy coming out there it's
the beach and people it's great I
forgive my ignorance but but you're
married I I see this oh yeah married man
I locked it down before I go
impotent um you know I had a good run
and now I'm uh now I got a nice lady I
think I have a couple Rugrats at some
point yeah where didd you meet your lady
at a show I met her at a show she was on
a date a bad date with a guy and I had a
I had a good set and she said [__] this
queef who's he really were they sitting
in the front sitting in the front I
didn't even think twice about it I she
like a hot lady and uh she does porn as
well no I'm just kidding um hot lady and
some guy and then I got got a DM right
after the show and she quoted one of my
jokes I said let's get a drink and the
rest is anal wow um and how long you
been married uh six months wow so it's
fresh yeah I give it a year no I'm just
kidding so you when last time we saw you
was right before you got married that's
right that's right I went I pulled the
trigger I went through with it and how
was the dating scene I mean did you C to
kiss a lot of frogs around New York like
just it's it's hard dating somebody when
you're touring right or did you have a
problem with that no no I mean again I I
really did the rounds you know I had
every STD In The Biz and uh you name it
did you ever think you're going to
settle down or you thought it was coming
one day never did I think most Comics
are like we got the Peter Pan complex
Bill bur has 35 minutes of material on
how marriage is stupid and how you
should never do it you lose half your
stuff and then here he is with two kids
living in the BBS with his black wife
yeah yeah and B bless his heart man yeah
she's great he's great and you're next I
I'm I am next man get married no pre are
you doing it I'm GNA get married whoa
who is he all right here's the thing
dude um and I've been very vocal about
this the because I've been engaged for a
long long time sure it's scary yeah it
is scary and the deal is that um my girl
and I are not having Rugrats I made sure
of that by getting a
vasectomy and
instead of having children we're going
to just be animal people so we've made
our plans for the future to buy a big
property and open up our own Animal
Sanctuary we've been waiting to get
married on that property and this is
going to be my first time announcing
this sure like we we found the property
like our offer has been accepted we're
on contract hell yeah 44
acres and uh and and that means the the
first thing we dudes we build our our
wedding venue on the property wow you
didn't say a city are you leaving that
out for now okay yeah you
bullied you really push hard it's just
outside of
Nashville Nashville call good call Great
area yeah they got open carry gun laws
there I'm really looking forward to that
yeah I can see you driving a truck
around Nashville you know you don't need
to get another car N I do need another
RV though I I love RVs
what can I say man RVs make me tick and
speaking of ticking what's going on with
your heart rate man do you know what it
is do you know if it's at dangerous
levels what's going on with your sleep
are you getting enough restorative sleep
what's going on with your exercise man
are you burning enough calories well
I'll tell you the answers to all of
these questions come from my whoop band
and I got the cool new stylish whoop
band they've got all different colors
and everything and what is it it's the
most sophisticated Fitness tracking
device known to man hands down I love it
I love my whoop and again all the
insights into your sleep your recovery
your exercise your everything man and
dude it makes me tick too so check it
out man go to whoop.com that's wh
o.com use the promo code steo and you
get 10% off a checkout plus they're on
the whoop 4.0 which is got the
waterproof charger the charger just
slides right on top you never have to
take it off it is always telling you
everything that you need to know about
your body and your well-being so one
more time go to whoop.com use the promo
code steo to get 10% off a checkout and
you're you're going to be a much
healthier person for it so let's get
back to it you think uh you're going to
practice that freedom that right the
open carry um I can't picture myself
being a gun guy but but um I too am in
the process of of working out material
in the in the clubs and uh I'm getting
into some gun stuff this time around all
that beastiality I'll give you some
material you know on you're you're out
there on the farm you're going to [__] a
horse it's going to happen y Mr hands
that's right man I'm uh going to do some
gun shopping my my next show wow you
going to hunt no I was thinking about
shooting
myself well that'll be your last
appearance on
Stern yeah that that that'll be good
yeah know it's exciting times man yeah
look at us growing up yeah it's exciting
times man when's the last time you ever
a
skateboard I picked one up this kid hit
me up uh and he said hey I I work for
some skate magazine you want to skate
around and I was so bad and I I did it
for like two hours and like it kind of
came back sure and then uh I he recorded
it and I landed a couple tricks and we
put it out and everybody's like look at
this guy's pretty good and I'm like no
no that took nine hours and I failed
most of it I think I I might have seen
this there it is that's it you were
skating a ledge yeah this yeah it's the
winner in New York oh you know you can
skip all the C oh jez we don't want to
see the [__] jokes the jokes yeah go
to you should go back and go to the
first one cuz wasn't that the Highlight
Reel how long are you going be in La I
leave Saturday to go to Balboa theater W
I've been here about a week man I'm I'm
having a skate party no Saturday yeah oh
I feel like a kid again yeah dude oh wow
we're gonna have some Heavy Hitters
who's who we talking the heaviest
hitters dude yeah uh I I can't
um Dayan said he's gonna try to make it
oh killer I love Tory pudwell was in
Japan for SLS also great Jeff ry's
confirmed what that when you when you
told me Raleigh was coming dude I was
like taking back D just so damped on
Jeff blowing people up who are going to
come but uh I watched him on the airw
walk video in like 1995 or something I
love Jeff rally right dude I'm I'm just
so hyped about it dude I'm so so amped
on my ramp I'm bummed I can't go to that
that wow dude that was a solid kickflip
right there hey thank you sir little pop
shove it there tow drag this is in New
York this is in New York yeah these kids
will hit me up like hey you used to
skate I'll film you and you know you try
to make it funny look at that pop shove
it out a little tow drag but hey how
many takes did that take you that was
about a,
and4
yeah and so way you grew up skating
around New Orleans oh yeah that was all
we did all day you know pre- internet we
would just skate from 9: to 9: skate and
jack off skate and jack off skate and
jack off then you watch skate videos at
night or you watch Jackass or you watch
whatever and that was our whole life and
it was great you uh skating mini ramps
and we built one in my backyard we stole
construction equipment over over time
and finally put a mini ramp together got
a little four-footer in my backyard nice
dude oh yeah I minus three and a half
unless you measure it from the flat okay
that's a good me from measure it from
the ground it's three and a half but the
Flat's 6 in high so it's technically a
three-footer you sound like the guy who
measures his dick like going all the way
back to the ball sack seven in like wait
you got 8 in of thigh on there what are
you doing you really Jam the ruler into
your pelvis get that extra inch and a
half did you post your skate did you
post your uh skate park uh skate ramp on
online I put I put uh a clip I have a
reel okay on my on my Ig yeah that's
cool yeah heavy skateboard sporting man
going on yeah that's a good looking ramp
you got there and that's a good s you
can't really get hurt on that you can
still do some tricks yeah I love it dude
I love it I wanted it mellow I wanted it
short but let's not alienate our our
audience here let's not let's not uh
yeah say something
[Music]
racist H these we got to Build That Wall
folks I I I had
a some [__] clip that but yeah sorry
I I had a wall joke at one point
I'm not really topical you know comedy
kind of guy but I would I enjoyed saying
that um the wall um Mex the the the
Trump's talking about they're going to
build the wall and Mexico's going to pay
for it yeah I don't see that happening I
think they're GNA pay for the tunnel
underneath it there you go you know
that's my joke boom how do you like that
I heard a I heard a great that's a good
one I heard a guy Dan Boulder out of
Boston has a great joke he's like
everybody gives a America [__] for
building a wall but China built a great
wall and I've never seen any Mexicans
there pretty good pretty good PR good
Dan buer I like that when you were
traveling around with Seinfeld did you
were you saying stuff like this or is
you kind of have to keep it real clean
well we just did we did about four gigs
and we talk comedy the whole time we're
both huge comedy nerds and I'm a huge
fan of his but he's a he's a regular
dude like he just likes cars baseball
and standup and we could we could shoot
the [__] for hours and he likes an
off-color joke I have a joke where I say
you know he's Jewish and I say uh I met
my my wife on that Jewish app
PayPal and we were you know he's a big
Jew and we were working on that joke and
I was like I wonder if I should say
venmo or PayPal and he goes you got to
say PayPal because it's got the word pay
in it that's more offensive and I was
like you're right yeah and it kills but
that was that was all him so he gets it
he loves prior and Bernie Mack and
Carlin and all that so he's he just
chooses to be clean for the challenge
yeah Carlin oh what a treasure what a
big fan big fan he huge hero of mine and
I met
him wow yeah did you ever meet him I
never met him I went to a book signing
and he he he zinged me pretty good yeah
people really like Carlin we we cut a
clip of Carrot Top talking about him and
Carlin together and that clip got
millions and millions views and I didn't
think you know people really well those
together is so odd that I think you have
to see that I would click on that in a
second krot top man I like him I like
him too he he owns it and he is who he
is and he's not changing and I respect
that have you ever seen one of his shows
live I love to I I saw Carrot Top uh the
same night after we recorded the podcast
oh that's sick loved it yeah you know
what's cool about Carrot Top Norm
McDonald my hero used to really Raz him
and when Norm died krot top played it at
his show and was like look how funny
Norm is you know he could see like yeah
he's just doing comedy yeah you know and
then carrot toop was cool enough to
allow himself to get made fun of in this
video which is like an epic you've
probably seen it the Conan video it's
one of the best moments in comedy
history I spaced out what you just said
pull this up that the go back and and
Happ to be a nor McDonald there it is so
he's on Conan with this this is in the
'90s with this
lady and you don't pay for [__]
YouTube jeez well we are in a
van thankfully with the Google app I can
search it with lens okay you can hit the
volume by the way there's an option to
turn that out there you go uh still
learning folks I don't want to give it
away it's it's it's sorry it's seven and
a half minutes it's too long to play on
here but the the gist of it is he's
[__] on Carrot Tops new movie
chairman of the board and he's calling
it box office poison he's killing and he
goes what's the name of it and Norman
goes chairman of the board and S and
Conan goes make a joke out of that and
he goes well it's a board spelled b o r
e d and Conan falls out of his chair
it's a great moment yeah it's hard to
get Norm I remember on one of the roast
people were trying to like you know bash
him and he just kept like reading his
newspaper and looking at like whose
roast was that that was uh was that
Chevy Chase Bob sag Bob sag sag he just
kept reading his paper so good he's the
king he's maybe the one of the funniest
people that ever live I think
what did uh what did PeeWee Herman die
of did it say what cancer it was I think
it was the cancer you get from jerking
off in a movie
theater I don't know what cancer that
was I was watching because Danny Elfin
had a tribute and they played some PB
Herman and there he's doing some music
at a show I was a huge Peewee guy yeah
Large Marge oh yeah yeah dude brain
tumor bra brain tumor scary [__] but he
lived man he's got photos with everybody
everybody loved peewee I met Peewee one
time really oh that's sick yeah did you
C with them I think it was uh at Fallon
Oh I thought you going to say the porn
theater it was uh the NBC Studios in New
York what was that what was that like
what' you guys do I he was just there
and I just met him and he was kind of
quiet like was he in character or was he
oh wow I don't remember that time I met
him yeah you had a drink in your hand I
wouldn't imagine yeah wow dude I look
like a pile right there you don't
remember that I I mean I vaguely
remember I know yeah I remember that
night I remember I met Adam Sandler whoa
that night what was the event ah well it
looks like it was a spike something or
okay Spike TV what year was that that
would have been 2007 oh as the wheels
what are they selling here are they're
selling a photo of you I guess so you
get it for 500 bucks for a large
no offense but who's shelling that over
for this I mean it's a good pick you you
look cool and he's terrified whose
lipstick is that on you you even know H
I do know whose lipstick that
was oh baby got to save for Howard
Stern yeah wow that that that was Kat
Von D's lipstick nice she did wear a lot
of lipstick oh guys Choice Awards you
couldn't do that now no no guys choice
you couldn't huh no this whole channel
would be labeled toxic you know cuz it
was like cars and boobs and stuff that
was like during the man show era right
Maxim magazine there was a lot of that
going
around good times that was a great
show all right dude all right are we
running out of steam dude I could keep
going I didn't I felt like I was cutting
people off so I didn't want to no that
I'm always just sensitive it is weird
everybody's dying like Peewee died
Prince is dead David Bowie's dead Tom
Petty's dead sheno Conor's dead I mean
this is this is terrifying yeah I
thought Shena Connor was dead
already you know I I hadn't heard from
her in a long time yeah she was kind of
weirdly hot you she had the head shaved
and she's tearing up pictures of the
Pope but if you got to look at her mug
it was a good mug pull up a a picture of
her with hair how did she pass I think
cancer N I think she was a suicide
no is that right I believe she was a
suicide interesting took her long
enough you'd think she knocked that out
earlier she had that thick Irish accent
which I love oh maybe she's British
never mind no she's from Ireland dou oh
cause of death was not stated oh I guess
you're right so when they say that that
means it's a suicide
definitely ah right there she does look
pretty dope yeah that's a pretty lady
yeah was like 198 83 yeah that helps but
not the middle one right there kids are
hot
yeah oh she looks rough there well look
at that's a that's a nice face with the
black turtleneck yeah who who who that
one actress really took a turn uh she
was on uh surviving the stone or um oh
um yeah she went to my high school in
London England Kathleen Turner K Turner
she was unbelievable Romancing the Stone
she was [__] drop dead just and then
and then I saw her again and she was
just Haggard Are You Going you going to
be mean to people now huh yeah what the
hell man next next thing you know he's
gonna be talking about uh Bridget
Fonda Bridget Fonda wait is she the old
lady with Lily Tomlin no that's Jane
Fonda Jane fond who still looks amazing
by the way bridet Fonda was the girl
that would play the
uh the Hitman in the80s movie Super yeah
she was like my first Crush what she's
not hot anymore well everybody gets old
I mean we're human here guys age pretty
well if they don't yeah Tom Cruz looks
great Tom Cruz is fake oh yeah no I
don't know he's probably like dude Paul
brisy said he said man can you imagine
if it wasn't for Scientology Tom Cruz
would be the coolest guy who ever lived
that baby blood keeps you young
though yeah he's probably drinking some
yeah why not what is it called
adrenochrome that's the one yeah you
think that's true I don't think so no I
just like to joke but you know I'm in Q
andon so what the
hell with the TV just turned off the
whole van turned off yeah we lost power
in the van oh [__] oh we lost power in
the van probably because of the heat are
the mics working yeah M the mics are
plugged into that big ass battery pack
they're listening to ass they know
you're saying [__] yes Scientology Put A
Spell On Us you ever try to go to that
building they will kick your ass right
out there somebody told me it's a hotel
you can stay in too no way and I said
[__] and he's like no I swear to God
it's a cheap hotel you can stay in it's
beautiful wow wa what's the billboard it
says uh are you curious why so many
people are
scientologists well it's an odd group
it's Tom Cruz number one I'm not
curious I I don't think there's really
that many everybody's falling out well
the rumors they got something on you
like you tell them you ran over a kid in
198 4 and you know they get you out of
it yeah they get you out of it but they
go but we know so you got to stay in
this or we'll we'll leak it they get you
out of it I thought that their whole
deal was like okay now how Scientology
works is you tell us all the bad stuff
you've done yeah that's what I'm saying
and they get you out of it I didn't know
that well if you kill someone they cover
it's like right they own everything but
I mean look who Travolta kind of went
cuckoo Will Smith obviously is a Will
Smith Scientologist I didn't know that
oh yeah that's where that anger came
from that and his wife [__] other
men which is very well documented that's
not me
speaking Yeah there you go the red table
horeshit yeah uh who else oh yeah that
uh Brook Shield oh yeah man that's sad
the that Z that 70s kid yeah the guy who
just got in trouble mcms was he Sai and
uh Danny masteron I know so he left
Scientology and then now he's going down
then you had cour cases I don't know I
don't know I don't know if that's the
case I'm going Muslim I'm going to do a
curve ball go Muslim at the end yeah
yeah your said would do great in the
Middle East oh yeah that would be fun
I'll cut my head off about Muhammad the
whole deal oh yeah they love that you
know Comics hear a [__] about hey
cancelling and you can't say [__]
they'll cut your head off go do a
Muhammad joke over there they'll [__]
put a hot poker up your ass till you die
yeah you you had a a tweet that was so
funny to me it was uh um Allah abbar is
like let's go for white guys Allah yeah
let's go is ALU Akbar for white guys
let's go white guys love saying let's go
yeah it's all
abbar yeah I think the funniest tweet I
ever read please was by Jeff Ross okay
okay he tweeted this TMZ article it was
like that it was like the day it
happened the Magic Castle here at the uh
the Magic Castle on Highland yeah and
they they found a
magician dead he had hung himself in a
closet at the Magic Castle all right and
um Jeff Ross tweeted the TMZ article
with his own little caption he says his
last words were Abra kadaver oh I love
it I love it
day I love I love a good joke yeah my
favorite meme was uh the one where
there's a video of trump kind of like at
the press conference
like and then he's just like did you
pull
out you know it's always like a funny
joke with like guy friends it's like do
you have sex out L and you know they're
like yeah like do you use a rubber yeah
no and everybody just laughs I don't
know why that's so funny that's funny
that's great I had one of the
Bachelorette was coming on and they the
the headline was I don't know who New
York Post said uh was Bachelorette was
forced to choose a black woman you know
and I wrote
uh I and now now you know how I feel
Dash Joe
Biden because a comma yeah but I did it
right when that was all happening and
that that one really blew up that the
people like it or they outraged yeah a
little both but that's you know part of
it did you have the joke in your last
special about the uh Miss Miss America
or Miss Universe that was trans is that
you I had a a Down syndrome Victoria
Secret model joke I had a lot of those
uh no I don't have the trans one but
that's true though right there was a
Victoria Secret model that was had Down
syndrome yes and she was cute she's
really pretty the joke was I'd go Downs
on her you know which is an easy joke
yeah and then I said I feel sorry for
the women the woman who didn't get the
job like I didn't get it who got it you
don't want to know kill yourself get out
of town change careers yeah good
times that's there a Down syndrome
Barbie now I mean they're having a
moment are they really they have that
good for them yeah yeah why not yeah
they exist I don't think they're buying
stuff I mean you could give them just
like a a bucket of paste and they'll be
happy but uh you know gave them some
candy but yeah good for them they're
having a moment yeah there's that like
hdden camera show where they where they
jumped out and they scared this lady
walking by but she had like some sort of
down syndrome and she was just like had
a full [__] meltdown and they're like
oh my God I'm so sorry I'm so sorry and
like the lady just flipped her [__] wow
and it was just the wrong person to
[__] do that too and they're strong
you don't want to [__] with them they'll
flip a car over yeah and then hump it um
did you see the Barbie movie I have not
I would like to but I have not seen it I
like Margot Rob I I've only
heard positive feedback
about it seems like every chick I know
has seen it twice wow and every dude I
know who has seen it said good things
about it yeah yeah okay I heard it's
beautifully done I heard Ryan Gosling's
hilarious I heard it's Greta Gerwig
who's always good she directed it I
heard that Barbie is actually a doll in
the movie how's it how do you do that
it's like a real act a liveaction movie
about a real doll really I didn't hear
that I don't know that maybe Lux is
pulling my leg but she said that um it's
about she's actually a doll in the movie
what about
Oppenheimer I saw it I I couldn't really
get into it oh come on really did you
like it I never saw I haven't seen it
either but I'm excited I love Nolan I
love the story it it's not bad it's
Don't Tell Me How It
Ends it's not bad but I was just like
man you know like I'm the guy who
watches a movie that's based on a true
story and then goes immediately to watch
the do the Real documentary yes which is
always better yeah yeah and um I was
just kind of in the movie theater
thinking like man I'm like very
interested in like the documentary I'm
gonna like that a lot more yeah yeah
totally I heard it's it's do we need a
three-hour plus movie all we talk about
is our attention spans are going away
and now they're making movies longer
yeah like the the during the pandemic
they did the Martin score sayy was 4
hours oh IR F what are we doing here I
know it took me six times to watch yeah
edit the [__] what do you J appow cut it
down and uh the defense of Oppenheimer
did not feel like three hours okay okay
I had to pee I did leave the theater to
pee at one point but did you go by
yourself no I went with Lux
IMAX I don't know no no climax we we did
the one um where you recline in the
seats oh those those big leather chairs
they sometimes they vibrate it's fun I
should have seen brokeback in one of
those I get my ass pounded you have a
you have a favorite movie favorite movie
Jes I don't know Cuckoo's Nest is great
uh Cool Hand Luke I love um I love
something about Mary I'm all over the
road I I got a lot of movies I love yeah
yeah I like go brother Rell Cool Hand
Luke probably sha Shank Redemption oh uh
what's it called No Country for Old Men
two so good yeah good
list two bears one cave yeah they don't
make good movies yeah the movies are
[__] you know cuz you heard about the
DVD sales like an office space was a
great comedy Mike Judge yeah it bombed
in theaters but you would make the money
back on the DVD sales which were through
the roof because it was like a word of
mouth cult classic now the DVDs are gone
you're [__] but I think it yeah get a
second life on streamers though but
there's a lot of dog [__] on streamers
right um yeah they just had that big
weekend of uh Sebastian versus Bert
that's right there and um my father what
was the was the Sebastian movie uh yeah
about my father BT had the machine right
those are both on Netflix uh no but uh
but apparently um Bert's movie I mean
the the narrative was that they didn't
like perform very well at the box office
but I'm told Bert's movie stands to
become very profitable in its
pay-per-view next windows I heard the
same thing with streaming you know
whatever the the BS movie is really
going to come out on top of that yeah I
would rather watch a movie streaming
than in the movie theaters now for some
reason of course the pandemic changed
all that I think it did and it's like I
I hate Marvel movies DC like all that
[__] unless it's like a wolverine or
something like that and like that's all
that you that's there for it's like
saying I you know these guys find little
things to nitpick but like it's true
like all Marvel movies suck except for
you know Wolverine or Batman or I don't
neither of those are Marvel I think
those are DC same [__] who Wolverine is
Marvel Batman's DC okay yeah but yeah I
get it's such a weird sentence I hate
these Marvel movies but I love Wolverine
you know yeah but like just completely
different I I I hate men but I love a
good
sack yeah yeah fair enough but I know
what you mean Hugh Jackman's awesome of
course yeah it's a great it's a great
time but yeah people go see that cuz
that's a theater movie I got to go see
[__] Iron Man in the theater Iron Man
one's great Deadpool's great great but
like the The Avengers or all the [__]
[__] like I can't even I know we're
down to Hawkman and Thor when did Thor
get B big [__] Thor yeah venom venom
we're scraping the barrel here what's
next colostomy man you know like come on
it's too much with the blue beetle is
the new one who the [__] never heard of
Blue Beetle Ant-Man Ant-Man get out of
here Blue Beetle that's a real one yeah
Billboards all over town for Blue Beetle
really it looks like George Lopez is in
that one no that's who plays Blue Beetle
no but he plays like he might be the
father of Blue Beetle or something oh
great I've heard some crazy crazy
stories about George Lopez really oh
late on can we get not suitable for
speaking at a public level o easy what
do you got you brought it up yeah I'll
tell you what why don't we wrap this up
right here and and I'll tell you some
stuff oh boy what a tease to the
listeners yeah go ahead and Google it
all right give it a Google Lopez is
gonna love
this thanks steo what are you doing to
me yeah I didn't I'm not he's like what
did I do right yeah I'm not saying if
it's good or bad I'm just saying it's
crazy stories you're talking about
George LZ Tacos yeah I'm not I'm not did
I say that it was bad no no I just said
it's not maybe it's not my place okay
tell about his charitable
[Music]
efforts you know I don't need to be
patting his back at a public level it's
not necessarily appropriate yeah yeah
but with that said man dude I [__] I
really really like you Mark I like you
steo you guys are awesome I I I posted
that thing on Instagram where I added
you and I realiz man I'm not following
this guy I'll follow back yeah well dude
I I uh well we're older you're not
following me I'm like I don't even know
how to work this [__] I don't it doesn't
I like you I'm here with you now what is
what is following trust me I wasn't I
wasn't offended I wasn't I didn't way or
another I'm not even following my wife I
uh I'm very I'm just I'm a big fan of
yours oh it's mutual I uh just you know
like we we talked to so many people on
this podcast and it's just it's just
such a you're the fourth funniest we've
had I'll take it that's pretty good the
Eric Andre episode was killer oh well
thanks man the we just did the longest
one ever oh who was it Oliver tree
Oliver tree he you've seen him you just
might not know the name very unique guy
but uh but yeah man I I hope that our
paths cross they will I'll be Head New
York at the end of the month oh great
heading to New York at the end of the
month I'd love to you have a skate sash
I'd let's do it I'd love to jump into uh
the cellar and and work on some stuff
we'll get you there that' be sick we'll
get you in there I got I got some pull
over there right on yeah I'll bring my
board we'll we'll rip it up okay last
last thing where are we sending people
oh markn Norman comedy.com for tickets
dates videos you name it I'm all over
the road big tour and uh Soup To Nuts on
Netflix check it out funny really
[__] funny thank you man I appreciate
it anything else uh Hey praise Allah and
uh don't touch
kids as I say in a van hypocritical I
love that man thank you brother hey
thank you man fun times yeah very cool
hey comedy one [__] funny cat oh
thanks guys it was a you guys are a good
audience how about that was that a wild
episode or what the Howard J Stuff felt
pretty controversial and it was like
really emotional for for me man I grieve
the loss of my relationship with the
Howard Stern Show I grieve for it I'm
hurt by it but hey man um let me tell
you this uh Mark Norman I love the guy
and I love his we might be drunk podcast
co-host Sam Marill now you might know
that our last episode was Sam
maril and I'm a little nervous that
it's going to look a lot like Mark
Norman is way more popular than Sam
maril if you guys don't hop back to last
week's episode and get your eyes on it
we don't want Mark Norman to outperform
his bro so if you didn't see that Sam
maril podcast then jump back to last
week because I don't want any hurt
feelings between those two
dudes
okay all right man I love you guys the
street team did I tell you that we're
making street team t-shirts I said it
last week but looks like a lot of people
didn't hear that because that samarel
podcast is kind of uh petering it's kind
of Putt and putt putting along anyway I
love everybody I love you thank you
guys